hello and welcome to another wx python
tutorial in this tutorial we're going to
be building off of the last wx python
tutorial and this is what we had last
time we'll just run it real quick and we
got this little window to pop up for us
and we just kind of changed the title of
the window but we didn't really specify
anything else
for this window
so i'm going to show you there there's a
bunch of different specifications
so to speak that you can give
your windows
so some of the things that we can do you
can just apply basically some stylistic
uh things to these windows
so to do that we'll just add to it you
just add another comma then you just say
style equals and here you just specify
everything if you don't specify
everything
with this frame now keep in mind this is
a frame now within the frame you're
going to have different things but as
far as the frame or the
window is concerned basically this part
the thing that goes around the window
like a frame does to a picture
if you just leave this empty it'll be
empty otherwise you can start specifying
things that you want like we want
a
maximize box
and that's going to be to maximize the
window
we want
wx
system
menu
let's just come down here we also want
wx we want a resize button
actually let's not do a resize button
we'll just do this and then we'll say uh
wx close box
oops
and then we also want
um
wx caption
okay so we're gonna say we want all
these things so obviously we didn't we
said we didn't want
a
um
a resizable border to this window so
we'll save this we'll run it hopefully
doing okay yeah so here we go
and sure enough like there's no no way
for me to resize
oops this window
okay so now the other things that we can
do we also didn't have a minimize so
there's no way for me to like minimize
this window i could like move it
somewhere but i can't uh window shake i
hate window shake anyway i just i can
move it somewhere but i can't
um at least push the minimize button
same thing if you go down to
um
your properties like let me just let me
scroll this down here to these
properties
and so here you can see this is the
python window here and if we come over
to here and we right click i can't even
minimize it even from that point and so
now let me show you something
a little
demonic
so i know what you guys are thinking the
the bad ones amongst you what if
we get rid of this
get rid of the clothes box that sounds
pretty nasty so we'll save that
run it
and here comes our window and oh my
goodness we can't close it we could we
can make it as big as we want we can
make it small we also can't resize it
but we can't close it now what if we
come back down here
to that window
and we bring this up and we right click
it
we still have no close option
but what you can do is just
click your clothes depending on i think
with probably vista and probably xp and
windows 7 you can just hit that x for
anyone else i'm really sorry for what i
just did to you now
continuing right along
you'll have to access your control alt
delete if you can't get rid of it but
anyway just kind of comical
um so yeah that's how you do kind of the
buttons on the window naturally i really
wouldn't change any of those
the only thing you might want to do away
with is the resizable
function
but you'll see in a minute that you can
spawn that window to be any size so with
that
eventually you're going to want to put
um something within this frame so what
you really need to do is to find a
basically a class for the frame so
that's what we're going to go ahead and
do and we're going to set this up and
then this will kind of be the template
that you'll use
for making windows
in the future
so
what we're going to start with now is
we're going to define a class and we're
just going to say class and this will be
window class
and then here you just put wx frame for
the parameter
and then here what you do is you define
it and that's
underscore underscore init underscore
underscore and basically what this does
is make sure that this uh it's short for
initializes so you don't actually have
to
um
call it it so as soon as like the
program begins it's going to do this so
with that let me just put in these
parameters here self
parent and then title whatever the you
want that title to be and i'll show you
it's just like any other function really
you give these definitions so next
um
we'll say it's super
and
we're just going to call window class
here self
and then die in it
and then we're just going to say it's
parent
and the title is going to equal title
which i'll show you
you'll really shall follow in a second
and then you can also follow with a size
parameter so like if instead of so if
you wanted to take away the ability to
resize you could
uh and then you can specify like or you
can just specify a specific size like
size equals
um
800 comma 600 okay for example and so
like this will make it 800 wide by 600
tall
um
and then you're obviously going to want
to do
self dot show so the window actually
shows and then down here we'll just do
the iconic
actually yeah we'll just do app equals
wx dot app
because you need that then we'll do
window class
and we'll say none we want it to be the
main window here so it has no parent and
then we'll call the title epic window
and then finally we'll call that a
little main loop there
main loop
we'll save it we'll run it
and sure enough here's our epic window
it's too big to even fit in my little uh
recording but this is the epic window
let's make it a little smaller we'll
make it uh
200 by 300
so 200 wide 300 tall
here it is epic window and then we can
resize it so we can actually read the
title
so that's our new epic window those are
how you can kind of change the sizes
because that's probably the size
changing is probably like the number one
thing besides the title of the window uh
you'll want to be able to change uh
easily
so the next thing you'll see is like on
this screen for example when i hit run
to run this i'm having to drag the
window over it's coming from a different
part of my screen so what if you know
this is where we want the window to pop
up right
you can do
a move command so what we'll do with
this is we'll say self
move
and let's move it 800
and down to 50. so it's going to move it
over 800 and down 250. it's just like
html where it starts at the top left
basically and it's going to move that
around so we're going to say we want to
move it 800 um
over to the right and 250 pixels down
from where it's been spawning and let's
see if it spawns on top of where we are
now almost it's just barely above so now
we can drop it down i don't know we'll
try like 350.
we'll run that and there it is so now
it's actually showing up at least within
this window area we can move it even
over a little bit further so we can say
we want it
thousand pixels
and now it's popping up here so anyway
as you can see um you can use that to
dictate exactly where a window might pop
up on screen
now finally there's also a command for
you can just say like if you want that
window to appear at the center of the
screen you can use self dot
center only it's sentry like center i
don't even know if that's like british
spelling or what
however i can't really show you this
it's it won't center on my screens i
think it's probably because i've got a
bunch of monitors so it just doesn't
want to i don't think it knows where to
go
so i don't really know but it doesn't
work for me so i can't really show it to
you but you can try that out so instead
of like moving the window you can say
center it and maybe once we've
initialized like we put a window within
a window and start utilizing windows
section
we'll be able to center a window within
that window i believe so anyway we'll
get we'll get to that point but um just
for now i'm just going to tell you that
there's also this command i just can't
use it myself
so anyways that's going to conclude this
tutorial um the next one we'll be
talking about doing like menu bars and
stuff because right now our window is
pretty uh
boring we've got a title and we learned
how to resize it and stuff but you can't
really do anything like we can't do
literally anything um so it'd be nice to
have like a menu bar that we can maybe
choose some stuff and
yeah so
in the next tutorial i'm going to show
you guys how to do a menu bar